Sort of roundabout way I got into the
story because my,
my great grandmother,
sister and my great grandmother
immigrated to the United States from
Slovenia in Nineteen Oh,
five.
And one weekend my great grandmother's
sister went to Chicago and was never
heard from again.
Um,
and I,
you know,
it was always intrigued about this and
didn't really know much about the story.
Nobody in my family had any,
um,
really,
traceable information.
But I thought it would be interesting
just to explore the circumstances that
could have led to her disappearance.
And because I knew Chicago was a pretty
dynamic and dangerous place at the time.
So I just started going through
microfilm,
a Chicago Tribune Microfilm and 19 and
five and came upon the marshal field
junior shooting and was immediately
intrigued by that because it was huge
news.
And um,
soon after coming upon this shooting,
I found the everlys sisters.
And,
and then of course,
you know,
forgot all about my missing relative
because they were so much more
interesting.
I,
I never cared to know.
Once I,
like I said,
once I came upon the elderly sisters,
I didn't care about finding anything
about her,
but I got an email a few months ago from
somebody who said,
you know,
Dear Karen,
I'm not a stalker,
but I found your great grandmother and
the Ellis Island records,
um,
and it seems,
and I fell,
so found another woman named Maria who
came over with her non nine in 1905.
But in 19.
Oh four.
Um,
and they both settled in Pittsburgh,
which is where my family had settled and
the person said they tried to track to
see if this woman went to Chicago,
but there was no record of her in
Chicago,
which if,
if it were her was,
her,
wouldn't have been surprising.
Um,
you know,
being that she was a poor immigrant.
Um,
and if so she did disappear.
It certainly would have been high on the
police departments,
um,
priority list to sort of track down and
see what happened to her.
So that was the closest I got to,
to um,
any other clue.
And I assumed that that was probably.
Well,
the sister is a good question because
they were very,
um,
part of their main facet of their
personalities was their ability to sort
of camouflage who they are and to keep
changing who they were and to change
their backstory so frequently that,
that nobody really could pin them down
and they told people they were from
Kentucky,
they told people they were from Virginia
and they told people they were from
Indiana and I was able to pin down that
they were in fact from this wealthy
family in Virginia.
Um,
but they had fallen on hard times and
nobody knew the really sad part of their
story,
which was that their father is the one
who forced them into prostitution at a
very young age.
Um,
and they of course lead everybody to
believe that they just decided to become
mad.
I'm just on a whim,
um,
after sort of coming into an inheritance
enjoining a theatrical troupe and,
and seeing that this might be a good
business opportunity.
Um,
so,
so there was a sort of sad undercurrent
to their story that,
that was really interest.
I think it was,
it was terrible.
Things,
I do think that they were colored by
their experience,
um,
and,
and being forced to be prostitutes
themselves.
Um,
they,
like many people who became magnums,
they began in the business like that and
I think that they were subjected to such
degradation that they really would
concern them,
that they wanted girls that they had not
to be.
They wanted to spoil their girls,
not exploit them.
They wanted to treat them as they wish
they had been treated.
Um,
I think that was a large part of it.
I think the other thing was they saw,
looked around and,
and we're realists and saw that there
was not much opportunity for women.
This is 100 years ago,
women couldn't vote.
A women couldn't even enter saloons
where politics were discussed.
I mean,
there was absolutely no way for women to
enter political discourse or,
or have a say in anything.
Um,
and all of these reformers who were
trying to quote unquote help these
women,
um,
these sisters were actually doing work
concretely to help these women than they
were,
you know,
providing them with food and clothes
and,
and meals.
Just from me of something funny
Minnesota,
she said it entertaining,
most men in the parlors is more tiresome
than with the girls lose their social
standing over.
Um,
so,
so yeah,
girls were lose,
lost our social standing by being
promiscuous by being prostitutes.
A lot of girls in fact were kicked out
of their home for being promiscuous.
I mean,
it was such as considered such a
egregious offense back then that you
could actually be kicked out of your
home and a lot of them enter
prostitution.
Figuring,
well,
if I'm going to be kicked out of my
home,
I might as well be paid for it.
What?
Of course,
it was a huge stigma.
Um,
and I think the elderly sisters,
part of their,
part of their goal was to help girls to
reform themselves in terms of returning
them back to polite society if that's
what their ultimate goal was.
A lot of their girls ended up after
leaving the club,
marrying into wealthy families across
the United States.
I'm marrying senators and prominent
businessmen and whatnot.
Um,
so,
you know,
men,
of course there wasn't a stigma.
In fact,
that was a badge of honor to be admitted
into the everly club.
Of course,
the usual double standard applied,
but,
you know,
the everly clubbed seemed to be the one
place where girls could sort of overcome
that,
that stigma,
I think part
of their power came from,
from the fact that they were able to.
So I'm so completely covered there pass.
I'm in the book,
I call them in 19th century amalgamation
of Martha Stewart and Madonna.
Um,
because they just kept reinventing
themselves and reinventing themselves.
And I even think that minute in,
by the time they were older,
they believed every lie they ever told.
Um,
I think that they completely bought into
the idea that they were aristocratic
ladies who had these,
you know,
privileged,
lovely upbringings and,
and never had a hard day in her life.
Um,
I think that by that point that that's
their story and they were sticking to it
and no one really had any right or,
or a reason
to know anything different.
The early sisters wielded tremendous
power and part of the reason they went
into this business,
it was,
if you think about it,
it was the only viable,
um,
business where a woman could actually be
the commander,
not the commander in chief,
the CEO,
if you will.
I mean,
it was the only women did not run in the
street.
They weren't masters of their domain.
This was the only industry where women
could actually assume a position of
power.
And the everglades sisters were very
powerful in that regard.
They,
they dictated who was allowed on their
club and who wasn't.
They had a very specific set of rules,
um,
you know,
in the men paid dearly for that.
And I think,
uh,
the sisters felt that if anyone was
being exploited,
it was the men in this equation,
um,
especially in light of the fact that the
way they treated their women and made
sure that the women were never abused by
these men are mistreated by these men.
Um,
I can't say the same for other,
for other brothels.
Um,
I think that,
um,
especially when the men were in charge,
either there were there,
um,
the,
the exchange of power,
much difference.
This all was one of my favorites
characters.
Um,
she,
she was the rival Matt,
I'm the rival Madam to the everly
sisters and,
and sort of was the Queen Bee Madam
until they came to town and,
and um,
you know,
had,
had worked her way up and spent quite a
bit of time and effort really
establishing herself in Chicago and she
was this scrappy,
relentless woman who was not uptown,
you know,
she didn't even know what I've tabbed
looked like and she did not at all
appreciate these two sort of
aristocratic sister sauntering in with
their,
they're flying ehrs and,
and sort of taking what she thought was
rightfully hers.
And um,
the fact that you tried to frame them
for murder twice as a,
it was,
I,
I mean,
I just couldn't have made her up.
And I always say if there's ever a film
adaptation,
a bet midler has to play.
Vic Shaw,
I actually sent back with a copy of the
book,
but I'm,
you know,
I'm sure she's,
she's going to call me any minute now
and want to do that.
But,
but,
uh,
you know,
I,
I really don't enjoy
the.